a cylindrical water storage tank open at
the top with a cross-sectional area of
10 ft discharges freely into a basin
below it out of a 6in orifice as
shown the flow rate at the initial time
of release is 5.5 cubic feet per second
by the time the tank is closed its flow
rate is 2.75 cubic feet per second what
is the volume of water lost in cubic
feet from the tank during this time
assume a discharge coefficient of 0.8
for the orifice so since this problem
mentions a discharge coefficient this
should make us think of some form of the
orifice equation there is a section in
the reference manual that deals directly
with orifices discharging freely into
the atmosphere so let's start there we
can see that the following equation is
provided in the
manual Q equal C
d
a of the cross-sectional area of the
flow leaving the
orifice time 2
GH Square Ro
TK if we solve this equation for the
height of the water at the initial flow
rate and the height of the water at the
final flow rate we will have the total
height that the water in the tank
dropped by then since we also know the
tank diameter we can calculate the total
volume of water that was lost so let's
get
started first thing we're going to do is
solve for the height of the tank at the
initial
discharge
so
5.5 cubic feet per second equals CD =
0.8 the area of the orifice we should
solve for
so =
PK d^2 over 4 = < *
0.5 ft
squared over 4
=
0.196 ft squared and while we're at it
we can just solve for the area of the
tank so that's going to be the same
thing
piun
* 10 ft^
squared over 4 equal
78.5 ft
squared okay so back to this part of the
problem let's solve for so a of the
orifice
is oh let's move this down just to give
us a little bit more room because I like
to be organized okay
a is going to be
0.196 feet
squared
time the square < TK of 2
*
32.2 ft per second
squared time H is what we're solving for
notice that H will be in feet so
the sum total of these units would be
feet squ over second squar square root
will take us back to feet per second
units will help to simplify and cancel
as we go through this anyway rearranging
for H here let's call this
H1 H1 is going to be equal to about
19.1
ft now if we solve
for the height at the time of the final
flow or at the final flow right there's
no time component here we can we can do
this again and get the height the second
height so
2.75 cubic feet per second =
0.8 *
0.196 ft
squared times again same thing up top
here square root of 2 *
32.2 feet perss squared *
H2 and
rearranging solving for H here is going
to give
us let's see
4.77
ft so our third step here would simply
be finding the difference of those two
heights so h 1 - H2
=
19.1 ft - 477 ft and that's going to
give us
14.33 ft so that would be the depth over
which the water in the tank
dropped over the period of time that the
water was
[Music]
flowing and since we have the area of
the
tank we can multiply this volume of
water
equals
14.33
ft
times
78.5 ft
squared and that should give
us
1124 ft cubed which is the closest
answer here is
1120 and that is all it takes to solve
this problem so there's nothing too
tricky here we just have to recognize
that we can solve for volume with the
equation for the orifice discharge and
the addition of our given information
about the dimensions of the tank and
that's it